Russia's defense Ministry has declared a
five-hour partial ceasefire to allow
residents of Two besieged Cities to
evacuate
humanitarian corridors are now open for
people in novel novaka and the Strategic
Port City of mariopol in Southeastern
Ukraine Maria Paul's mayor says the city
is without water and power and is
running out of food after being
surrounded by Russian forces
after days of Relentless shelling here
in the Keyport city of mariopol Russia
has said it will stop firing and allow
civilians to flee the partial ceasefire
was confirmed by the city's man and
applies here in the nearby town of Von
novaka which has seen heavy fighting as
well
but they're far from the only areas
devastated by Russian bombardment
President Vladimir solenski has been
pleading with NATO to set up a no-fly
zone to stop Russian airstrikes like
this one outside Kiev
but NATO has ruled that out an all-out
war in Europe that's what the alliance
wants to avoid according to U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken the
only way to actually Implement something
like a no-fly zone is to send NATO
planes into Ukrainian airspace and to
shoot down Russian planes and that could
lead to a full-fledged war in in Europe
President Biden has been clear that we
are not going to get into a war with
Russia as fighting enters the tenth day
the situation in Ukraine becomes more
and more desperate casualties are
mounting and over 1 million people have
now fled the country
there are reports of severe food and
water shortages in some cities including
Kiev
but president zielinski stressed on
Friday night that he's still at his post
in the capital
every second day the rumor appears that
I ran from Ukraine from Kiev or from my
office as you can see I'm here
in the occupied city of malitipole to
the South Russian soldiers hand out food
it's the second City in Ukraine set to
be under the invader's control after her
son
with Russian forces on the move across
the country and NATO ruling out
intervention
people here are preparing for a long
bitter battle ahead
our correspondent Fanny fashar is
joining me now she's in chair Nifty in
Western Ukraine funny uh Russian forces
will stop or have partly stopped already
firing to allow humanitarian corridors
out of the Ukrainian cities of Mario
Paul uh while novakar what do you know
about that
local authorities in Mario Paul have
just confirmed that that humanitarian
Corridor will start so people can be
evacuated during the day today now we
have to remind everyone here that Mario
Paul was heavily shelled during the past
couple of days people are not just
spending just their night in bomb
shelters but basically they were staying
there for days also the mayor of Mario
pool in a very emotional address in a
video address on Friday made clear that
that apparently there's no electricity
no running water so very basics of of of
what you need are missing are lacking
right now for people so it's very very
crucial time now to evacuate people as
uh as Ukrainian forces are expecting
that regardless whether this
humanitarian Corridor is going to be set
up that's not going to stop Russia to
ashle other cities in the meantime in
fact Russia's defense minister has just
said that they're going to continue with
their attacks there is hope now at least
for the citizens of my you pulled it at
least the citizens of that City in the
south is strategically uh located in a
southern part of Ukraine can leave
mariopol but let's really see how that's
going to turn out there are also
skepticism there's also skepticism on
the ground here after all uh after the
second round of the so-called peace
talks between Ukraine and Russian
delegations uh ceasefire and and
humanitarian corridors were also
promised and we haven't seen that unfold
but now that the local authorities in
mariopol are saying they believe that's
going to happen at least Hoops are
increasing for the people of Mario POA
and of course you mentioned it already
the intensity of the fighting of attacks
is increasing what's the situation where
you are
I'm here basically at the I would call
it a transit town towards the Romanian
border via about 50 kilometers
away from Romania and people who come
here internally displaced people from
Ukraine are trying to uh say let's say
for a couple of hours a couple of days
before they uh face that next challenge
crossing the border towards Romania
things here in addition are quite
peaceful I should say relatively
peaceful because of course we have heard
the sirens blaring during the past
couple of days people going to bomb
shelters here as well there is a
civilian airport nearby now Russia
claims they're not going to attack
civilian infrastructure on the military
units but of course we have seen that
during the past couple of days or in
fact I should rather say for more than a
week now that civilian infrastructure
has been also affected so people here in
this relatively peaceful uh town in the
southern western part of Ukraine are are
not a hundred percent sure obviously
just how long this town is going to
remain safe all right funny for sure
stay safe uh and thank you so much for
this report
and for more let's bring in Constantine
Eggert now he's a Russian political
analyst and he can tell us more about
the Russian perspective Constantine uh
let's first begin with this recent
development Russia ordering a ceasefire
to ensure humanitarian corridors what's
behind that move what does that mean
well unfortunately I think that behind
this move is uh a massive assault on uh
variable I think that this is a way for
the Quran to say well you see we made
everything possible to save the
civilians whoever didn't leave the city
well we have nothing more to do with
that we are not to blame
um as you probably see the offensive
seems to be focusing now not on taking
the cities which I think militarily is
quite uh quite safe because trying to
storm even mariopu will mean house to
house fighting which inflicts huge
casualties on the attacking side but I
think it's actually besieging the cities
including an important part of mariopol
and shelling them indiscriminately and
this is really really I'm afraid very
bad news for the civilian population and
this seems to be the tactic now or even
the strategy of the Russian dance in
Ukraine which has been losing Steam and
which seems to be uh ground into a hole
that's where it will be I mean it will
be quite difficult for the Russian
forces now to continue taking uh more
territory taking more cities controlling
more but they're certainly trying uh to
take more nuclear power plants uh the
U.S ambassador to the U.N says that
Russian forces are now closing in on
Ukraine's second largest nuclear power
plant uh after already seizing the
largest one on Friday what is Russia's
strategy here
well I am afraid there are two aims here
one is purely strategical to control a
significant part of Ukraine's energy
grid and supply of energy essentially
but the second thing is that
psychological power play which is very
much in the style of Vladimir Putin look
I'm so crazy I don't care if I show
nuclear power plants so hoping that the
West will rush to him and say well
whatever you want but just don't play
this tricks or not and I think that this
maybe even the main calculation in terms
of uh psychological uh Warfare with
Ukraine and Frankly Speaking With West I
suppose that this is one this is one of
the very few tools left in
um in in the Kremlin psych War uh
Arsenal and they are they are using
right concerning their political analyst
and Russia expert thank you so much